this is kind of random but I think it's
really cool one of my favorite things
about this makeup remover from bioderma
is how the two layers don't separate
quickly if you use these kinds of makeup
removers you'll know how annoying that
separation is you shake it and you have
to like race to get it onto your pad
before it separates if you get too much
oil it ends up greasy if you get too
much water then it doesn't take off eye
makeup that well and then halfway
through the bottle you've used up all
the oil but you still have tons of water
left I thought it was just like
coincidence that this works so well but
it turns out it's intentional and
bioderma have a patent for this it's
called ecob biological basic two layers
cosmetic composition with delayed phase
separation they use just the right
amount of polyglycerol 10 la which is a
surfactant it keeps the two layers mixed
together or emulsify for longer than you
need to get it out onto your cotton Pad
but then it still separates into two
layers by the next night